- I just fucking love the comfort
zone because this is life.
- Mazel tov, just don't
complain when your business
doesn't grow that much
over the next decade.
You're not feeding your business,
you're feeding yourself.
Good!
But you better fucking shut
up about why am I not growing.
You know why you're not
growing, you're not feeding it.
("Imminent Freestyle" by Aes Waves)
I think most people fear it being tough
when they're asking for something crazy.
Do you know how hard it
is to be a millionaire?
- [Man] It is very tough.
- [Gary] It's unbelievably hard.
- Yeah.
- 99% of people in the world
never even remotely get close.
Number one biggest
mistake all of you make is
you don't realize it's going
to take 21 years for success.
- [Man] 21 years for success?
- 21 years for success.
Now look, most people don't understand
what it is to do a million.
Everybody thinks everyone should
do a million, a million, a million.
I laugh at a million.
99% of the people watching
this video right now
or 31 years from now, because
everything will be online,
will never taste a million.
99% of you.
Now, when you internalize
that, all of a sudden
now you're going to
respect what you're asking.
I want people to respect their
audacious ambitions more.
I think the answer is to not over judge
yourself and to follow what you feel.
So you focus on doing, you
know, focus on the business.
But then, then if you wait
6 months and it feels good
and you're like, you know what?
I can sneak an eating
disorder course in real quick.
You know, don't hold somebody's opinion
higher than your feelings.
Just if you wanna do it, do it.
Because even if it
fails, you'll feel good.
- Yeah.
- Right, do you understand?
Even if it fails, you'll feel good.
Now I'm patient, which is a strength.
I don't judge others, but most
of all I don't judge myself.
When people talk about my
super-human time management
I'm actually terrible at it,
it's just that I don't judge
myself in my terribleness.
(woman laughing)
- The first way I always tell
solopreneurs they can grow
is by making less money personally.
I don't know your living situation
or how you live your life.
But if you're going on this
journey to build a business
the business matters more than you.
So I would want the roof over your head
to cost you less money.
I would like the food you put in
your mouth to cost less money.
You have to look at everything else
you're doing in your life.
And I mean this, you know,
how much time do you spend on marketing?
You said those four things, how much
time do you actually
spend on it, in a day?
Zero, sometimes, I assume?
- [Woman] Yeah, sometimes.
- In a week, how much do you spend on it?
- [Woman] Two hours.
- Two hours, great.
Now is the most important
part of this meeting.
How many hours do you sleep at night?
- [Woman] I have to have 7.
- Great.
So I love the way you said it.
I have to have 7.
So if I wanted to say go to
six, so that you pick up five
you're going to say to me,
Gary, I have to have 7 right?
Now let's go somewhere else.
I have to know what you're
doing the other 17 hours.
I would bet the house that we
can find an hour every day.
- [Woman] Okay.
- I guarantee it, because you
might be working all 17 hours
but you might not be
working on something smarter
than spending an hour a day on
the thing that you're talking about.
- [Woman] Right.
- Do you understand?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- That's the answer.
The answer is time.
You know, people talk about
working hard and working smart.
The answer is only both.
You have to work hard and
smart based on your ambition.
If you want to build a
business for yourself
that is like a one percent life.
Most people don't understand what
building a business for yourself is.
It's very special.
Trying to build a business for yourself,
everybody's doing now.
Pulling it off, trying to play basketball,
everybody can try.
Being an NBA player, trying
to be a rapper or a singer,
everybody's doing.
Pulling it off.
Trying to be a footballer, an actress.
Got it?
So you're trying, great.
Pulling it off is hard.
It takes everything, time and smarts.
You need 7, I'm glad you said it that way
because it makes this piece
of content more valuable.
It's the seventeen other hours.
I'll give you an example.
A lot of people drive
to work for 45 minutes.
If they took a bus for an
hour and fifteen minutes
they would save money
and get more work done.
But do you have the humility to
take the bus versus driving your car?
When you're letting other voices dictate
your behavior, it's always a bad idea.
- It's just scary, right?
- Sure, but what's the scariest thing?
You're wrong and you lose
and your company goes out of business?
Like, sure, but I think that
I would tell you, you have to
do what feels right to you.
And if doesn't feel right
to take outside money
and have all these voices, then don't.
It's the tortoise and the hare.
Either you're a rabbit or you're a turtle.
The turtle wins.
- Really?
- That's how the story ends.
- Honestly I feel like I'm the turtle.
- Go read the book.
The turtle wins.
(both laughing)
This is how you do it?
Okay, I got it.
- So do you eat much fruit in New York?
- I love fruit.
- You're better than me,
mine's going everywhere.
- I love mango steams.
- [Man] They're the best.
- So good.
- So yummy.
- [Man] They don't get
as nice ones in New York.
So that's why I was like, Bring him mine.
- This is actual, real.
- She was like, Bring him a
mango, bring him everything.
- So you're not going to invest as much
as properly needed because
you want to buy stuff.
By the way, mazel tov, enjoy.
You do you.
But that's the debate.
- Yeah, because a lot of people say
come off from the comfort zone but,
I just fucking love the
comfort zone, this is life.
- Mazel tov.
Just don't complain when
your business doesn't grow
that much over the next decade.
You're not feeding your business.
You're feeding yourself.
Good.
But you better fucking shut up about
Why am I not growing?
You know why you're not growing.
You're not feeding it.
So to answer your
question, why do I do it?
Because I love the process
more than the other stuff,
You love the other stuff
more than the process.
That's okay, I don't think I'm right.
That's just who we are.
So I'll probably build
billion dollar companies
and you won't, doesn't mean I'm right.
You might have more
vacations and eat more food
and go to more matches and
spend more time with people.
That's great!
Life is about choices.
But you can't have both.
And I think when there's a moment in time
that's special like this,
it's probably a good idea
to take advantage of it.
Because you can go back
to being comfortable
three years later, and by
the way, that comfortable
tends to be far better than
it was three years earlier.
They're true, we're just getting started.
- Just keep them on the set.
- [Woman] Where does these two go?
- Feels like you lost a
little pep to your step.
- A little step.
I'm supplying every store for tomorrow.
- A humbling experience, D-Rock.
- Enough.
- What?
- [Man] I'm in the comfort zone
and I like the comfort zone.
- And I love that, which is why,
if you noticed where I told
him, I said that's great,
but you better not be confused
why your business is flat.
You're siphoning all the money.
- [Man] Your point on the
comfort zone in three years
will be bigger is him not
remembering that three years ago
his comfort zone was less.
- Of course, people forget.
- [Woman] But, who wants
to go back three years ago,
comfort zone?
- [Gary] Nobody which is why
most people are not successful.
Like, this is not complicated.
The math is in a very obvious place.
Most people don't get to a million dollars
of earnings let alone per year and they do
the same behavior and they're confused.
It's not a subtle tactic.
Everyone is looking for a fucking tactic.
Like a hashtag or a fucking algorithm
is gonna fucking change it.
It's not that.
It's a fucking complete mindset
and lifestyle of humility
and fucking process.
It's fucking hard because
it should be hard.
It should be hard, D-Rock.
I understand, So you stopped caring
about what people thought.
- Yes, after which I actually
understand my own business.
I talked to my dad.
I thought I could make it overnight.
Because I thought starting
a business, it was easy.
- [Gary] That's right.
- But it was really
tough for me and I failed
and I made the promises
that I couldn't keep
and I failed my dad.
And something changed.
I knew after I met you that it's not
going to be overnight success.
- That's right.
- It's going to be a
lot of patience involved
and right now I'm actually documenting
my journey online so that--
- Which is huge.
- So that I will not be a bullshit.
Like, actually be an inspiration to others
and there's something that is--
- And you have a very
powerful story because
what you've already lived,
your truth is something
that a lot of kids go through, which is
because it started off a certain way,
you already tasted letting somebody down.
Which, to a lot of people,
is the biggest fear.
- Yes and I did not want to let my family
- Of course
- down.
- And I just struggled a lot.
I don't know how to get
in an let something--
- But you know what's so powerful
is that you're in so early.
Just because you have a loss early on,
you can overcome that very easily.
- Yes, and this journey helped me a lot.
You really called out my bullshit.
Like, I'm a bullshit!
I'm a bullshit!
My dad knows that.
And I didn't want everybody to know
so that's why I never posted online.
But right now, I'm posting it online.
So then, it's there--
- Because once you tell your
truth, instead of having fake,
you're no longer a prisoner to your fake.
- Yes, correct.
So right now, I'm starting
this night and day's journey
to slim down because I'm
always telling my dad
I'm going to lose weight
but then never do it.
But now I'm posting online
every day to just be there,
to let people know that
I'm not bullshit anymore,
that I'm going to change it.
And to be there five years
later to shake your hand,
cause I'm not shaking your
hand right now because I feel
like this is something
that I have to earn it.
- Accomplish.
- Yeah, like I have to earn it.
Like, do something, I have to earn it.
- [Gary] Makes me very happy.
- Yeah, I've come a long way.
- What about when you say
I called out your
bullshit in the beginning,
did you accept it right away, or was it--
- No, it was a journey.
It was tough for me to accept that
I was a bullshit because
my ego is too high
- Of course.
- And I didn't want--
- What about with my content?
Did you hate it at first?
- I didn't hate it.
I love you so much.
I mean, I respect you
a lot, I don't hate it.
But I just listened
and then I take action.
I never took the action.
- And so what happened?
Do you know?
- So I talk a big game
and my dad knows that
and so he was really angry with me
and then he was upset that
I never take any action.
But then that was the switch was
because I'm a foreigner here in Singapore
so I'm turning 21 this year
they say that I cannot hold
a different here anymore so I will have to
leave the country or find a job.
But the problem is that I
drop out from high school
so it's really tough for
me to get a regular job.
And it's also tough for me
to become an entrepreneur
so that was the switch for me.
It's time to do the actions,
it's time to make things change.
And to really say, what,
do, oh my goodness.
- Execute on what you say
you're gonna do, yeah.
No, that's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
- So it helped me to
understand the evolution.
And I accept that right now.
Before, it was hard.
- I totally understand.
I totally understand.
- Especially like people have
so amazing image outside.
Like people don't know who I am.
Like really inside me.
What is happening at home.
So I feel like, yeah
I'm free, I'm freer now.
Yeah, I just want to thank you
like so much, this is
always what I want to say.
That's why I volunteer to Chinese team.
I don't even know that was run by...
- Meng?
- Meng, yeah because I actually
get in touch with Skype.
- Yes.
- Yes, and I didn't know
that was the official.
I just wanna like give
you value in some way.
- Thank you so much.
That makes me so happy.
I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you so much!
You literally changed my whole life.
Thank you so much!
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, you're welcome.
- [Announcer] Please, give
it up for Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience cheers)
(music plays)
- [Man] Thank you!
- [Gary] The thing that
people need to understand
more than anything is what
is driving their ambition?
Why are you doing what you're doing?
What itch are you trying to scratch?
Are you trying to be successful to prove
the people who said you wouldn't?
Are you trying to be successful
because you love the process?
Are you doing it because you
wanna buy something fancy,
to show people that you're successful?
Why do you do what you're doing?
And most of all, for who?
(music plays)
So why the fuck am I
gonna listen to anybody?
And I promise you, you're
living that same life too.
Do the fucking thing that you wanna do,
stop fucking listening to other people,
start executing, get your head right,
and really get perspective,
you're a fuckin' miracle,
do something with it.
I fuckin' love you Singapore!
Stop fuckin' around and
take advantage of your life.
(Audience applauds)
- [Announcer] Give it up for Gary V!
(Audience cheers)
- Thank you!
Thank you!
Do Something!
("Imminent Freestyle" by Aes Waves)